على ما يبدو اعزائي انه بهذه الايام بايام
هادي ما عاد في شيء غريب ممكن انه يصير
هالمره من العراق وتحديدا من ملهى ليلي
بالعاصمه بغداد ظهرت طفل ما بيتجاوز عمره
12 سنه بمقطع فيديو عم يتمايل ويرقص ويلقي
بالاموال على احد الراقصات خلونا نشوف
[موسيقى]
بسيوني
طفل بهالعمر اخر مكان بالعالم لازم يتواجد
فيه هو الملهى الليلي للاسف الفيديو بعد
ما انتشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اعمل حاله جدل مش طبيعي خصوصا انه
القوانين العراقيه الغير مطبقه بتمنع دخول
الاطفال والقاصرين للنوادي الليليه ولا
الملاهي بس لحظه يا جماعه في شيء عن جد
انا شخصيا مش قادره استوعبه وهو تصرف
السلطات العراقيه لانها طالب تحديدا مدير
الشرطه المجتمعيه في العراق
العميد غالب العطيه طالب في منشور على
فيسبوك بمساعدته بالضبط في معرفه اسم
الطفل اللي ظهر في مقطع الملهى الليلي
يعني عن جد الشرطه العراقيه رايحه تدور
على الطفل وتركه صاحب
الاساس لدخول قاصرين
يعني بصراحه الموضوع مضحك ومبكي في ذات
الوقت
عموما في شيء ابدا ما بنقدر نجاهله ولا
نقدر نتخطى اصلا وهو كثير معروف بالنسبه
لها كثير ناس وهو سيطره الميليشيات
الولائيه على الملاهي الليليه في العراق
الموضوع هذا يا جماعه مش جديد فمن وقت ما
دا هو اقتصاد النظام الايراني بسبب
العقوبات الامريكيه بدات المليشيات
التابعه لايران في البحث عن مصادر تمويل
جديده وقتها بالفعل انتشره تقارير بتحكي
عن وجود نوع من الحمايه مقابل المال
بيفرضها عناصر من المليشيات على الملاهي
الليليه ودور القمار ومحل محلات بيع
مشروبات كحوليه في العراق وحتى نكون
واضحين اهداف المليشيات مش الحمايات اكيد
فهي اهداف غسيل الاموال والتهريب والاشجار
والبشر واللي هو مش غريب على ايران في
العراق
على كل حال عن هاي الحادثه المتكرره للاسف
في العراق معنا من اربيل الكاتب الصحفي
عماد باجلان اهلا بك استاذ عماد معنا
استاذ عماد خليني ابدا اللي حكيته قبل شوي
في المقدمه
هلا بالطفل اللي عمره 12 سنه اللي ما
بيعرف شو الصح من الغلط ولا اصحاب
ملهى ليلي ومن يدير وملهى ليلي بهذا الشكل
وبيسمحوا له قاصرين همم يدخلوا يعني
يعملوا اشياء بهذا الشكل وشجعوهم على ما
يبدو
بدايه سيده الفاضله تحيه لك والمشاهده
قناه العربيه الكرام بدون ان الشك المدير
الشرطه المجتمعيه لا يستطيع القاء القبض
على صاحب الملهى لين صاحب الماليه لديه
شركاء وهذه وهؤلاء الشركاء همم على الغالب
يكونون منتمين لاحزاب متنفذه في بغداد هذه
الدور القمار والملاهي كلهم لديهم همم
يعني اقول حمايه من احزاب متنفذه حاكمه في
بغداد فهنا الشرطه لا تستطيع النيل منهم
وقد سمعنا من قبل همم ايام همم يعني اقول
قبل القران ايضا اصبح هناك انتهاكات
والشرطه تحركت واصحاب المحل همم افرج عنهم
وهمم يعني غرقت القضيه يعني سيدتي مع مع
نشاهده الان في العراق للاسف يعني نتيجه
تراكمات وهمم تراكمات ونتائج الحروب التي
خاضها العراق
فاصبح الطفل الحلقه
في المجتمع العراقي يذهب الى المدرسه
يتعرض للعنف يذهب الى السوق يتعرف يتعرض
الى التحرش يرجع الى البيت يتعرض الى
التعنيف الاسري والى اخرين لماذا لان هناك
همم غياب لقوانين راضعه وقوانين حمايه
حقوق الطفل لذلك نقابه الابوين يعني هذا
منظر غير مقبول لطفل يعني ووو من غير
المنطقي انه النوم الطفل على هذا الشيء من
لون اهله من لوم القائمين على همم
الليلي والمسؤولين عن هذا الانحدار اصلا
سيدتي الطفل اصبح الحلقه الافضل اضعف
واصبح الضحيه في المجتمع العراقي يعني بكل
جوارب من كل الجوان ناحيتي عن مساله
التربيه اييه قبل في العراق كان لدينا
التربيه والتعليم للاسف الان لا يوجد
تربيه ويوجد تعليم فاشل فقط اما بالنسبه
للاهالي بالنسبه للابوين فهذه تعتمد على
ثقافاتهم على بيئتهم واصبح تغيير الشامل
في المجتمع العراقي منذ منذ عقدين او
ثلاثه على اقل تقدير في مساله التربيه
ومساله همم
العين يقول القيم الاخلاق الى اخره همم
لانه غياب الرقابه وغياب القوانين الرائعه
وغياب همم عيني اقول
الحكومه ومواقف الحكومه وغياب دور
المنظمات المجتمع المدني التي كانت الى حد
ما توعي الناس بعكس الحكومات التنفيذيه
ولكن لان
ايضا الاتحاد بالتجاره والادعيه يقول همم
الاموال وتركت ايضا هذا الجانب مساله
التوعيه والتوعيه الطفل خاصه فلذلك الوضع
في العراق بالنسبه للطفل المزري ووضع همم
دعيني اقول يعني سوداوي الى ابعد الحدود
ناهيجي عن انه كما ذكرت انه هناك همم قسم
من الميليشيات واحزاب متنفذه هم من يعني
يقول يعتمدون على همم اقتصاد واقتصاد ليس
بقليل من هذه الدور الملاهي والقمرات
والقمار وهذه الاماكن همم يعني لا احد
يستطيع للنقابات ولا المجتمع همم
ولا الشرطه المجتمعيه ووضع احد همم هذه
القوانين والسلوكيات انه يمنع الطفل بدون
18 دخول هذه المعركه ان هناك في الكثير من
هذه الدور همم فتياتها القس في عمر الرابع
عشر والثالثه عشر والخامسه عشر ايضا لم
تبلغ ا ا دعيني اقول السن القانوني ولا
احد يستطيع محاسبه اصحاب المحل لانهم كما
ذكرت همم شركاء مع ناس متنفدين في هذا
البلد للاسف
بصراحه في تناقض كبير بحيث انه بنشوف
فيديوهات مثل هاي بنشوف فيديوهات لقتل همم
فتيات بتاع همم الشرف يعني همم ومنلاقي
كمان بانه يعني من همم يعني همم
يحاول انه يروج لمثل هذه المناظر اللي
عملنا بنشوفها وبيحمي القائمين عليها هم
نفسهم اذرع مثلا ايران اللي بتسوق نفسها
على انه هي حما- حمايه الاخلاق وحاميه
الدين بين ما بتحكم على همم يعني فتيات
ايرانيات بالموت او تقتلهم لانه مش لابسين
الحجاب ولكن تسمح لي مثل هذا هذه المناظر
يعني في مناطق اخرى
يعني للاسف نحن لا نعتب على الدول بقدر
مانعاتب على الاشخاص الذين بيدهم
السلطات واشخاص الذين
لديهم السلطه
والحزبيه كانت السلطه القضائيه والسلطه
همم التنفيذيه ابناء البلد الذين يعضون
النظر عن هكذا اماكن وهكذا سلوكيات في حين
القانون العراقي كما ذكرتي واضح يمنع منع
بعد يعني هذه السلوكيات غير مطبق هنا هنا
نقطه هنا هنا
مربط الفرس انه لا يطبق وترينا ان هناك
قوانين تضر تضر يعني يضر بالشعب العراقي
ويطبق ولا ولا
يعملون على تغييره ولكن القوانين التي
تحمي الطفل
وترعى همم يعني همم
اخلاق المجتمع العراقي لا يطبقها هذا ما
جعل هذا يستفحل وينتشر في همم دعيني اقول
هكذا ما كانت في المراقص والبارات
والملاهي ودور القمار لانه لا يوجد عقابه
ولا ردع ولا دور ايجابي
قله التمويل من ايران الان في ظروف
الراهنه طبعا بعد العقوبات الامريكيه
عليها بدات تترجم على الارض بانه
الميليشيات التابعه لايران في العراق بدات
تبحث عن مصادر تمويل اخرى وللاسف اغلبها
غير نظيف
من الطبيعي جدا اي دوله اي دوله انا قلتها
قبل الان اي دوله تكون مكاني ايران ولدها
لديها ذراع ولديها ولا مطلق من دوله جاره
ان تفعل ما تريد يعني خاصه
حصار اقتصادي همم يعني كبير فلذلك باي
طريقه انه الاموال اذا تعود الى ايران
ولكن المشكله ليست في ايرانيين وفي
سياستهم وتفكيرهم بالقدر مع المشكله لدى
العراقيين الذين لديهم ولا مطلق لبلد جار
وليس لديهم ولاء لبلدهم هنا هنا المشكله
هنا تحديدا هنا المشكله ولكن انه همم
ايران ايران كيف لها ان تستطيع ان تعمل
كلها هذا في داخل العراق وهي دوله اذ لم
يكن لديها عراقيين عراقيين هم ازرق همم
يعتبرون همم ايران بلدهم الام ولاعهم
لايران اكثر بلدهم فهنا العتب ليس على
ايران بقدر ما هو العتب على همم اذرع
ايران في العراق اي كانت ال- ال- الطرق
سوف تعمل ايران لكسب الاموال للتنفس
اقتصاديا على اقل تعبير
كان معنا من اربيل